it's great to be joined today by Tim
boss who is the CEO and co-founder of
share ring and share ring is working
within the sharing economy and Tim I've
been super interested in the sharing
economy for a while not the least of
which is sort of an interest caused by
the fact that a lot of sharing economy
or supposed sharing economy businesses
really are ways where people are paid
sort of substandard wages often time and
it is very very profitable for the
companies that sort of control both the
platform and the parameters of how that
sharing takes place so I think first and
foremost it might be interesting to talk
a little bit about what is the problem
or the problems plural that you've
identified within the sharing economy
that you're hoping to work on so I guess
in terms of the sharing economy there's
a few different views on what the
sharing economy actually needs so we we
often look at Airbnb and uber and
companies like that and sort of look at
those peer-to-peer sort of sharing
economy businesses but in fact the
sharing economy has been with us for
many many many years
you know the rental of assets a car
rental company just a normal taxi
company they're all actually part of the
sharing of them so one of the things
that we're doing with sharing is
actually taking that fragmentation of
the sharing economy and bringing it into
a single marketplace so some of the
benefits with that are one login so you
only need to log in and have and show
your ID once through the platform to to
basically rent some some assets from
anywhere in the world there's no foreign
currency transfer fee so if you're going
to rent a car in say Thailand you don't
need to pay your your sort of foreign
currency transfer fees to rent that car
and also the security that we provide
around that so where we do the proper ID
validation we back it up with some
third-party insurance companies as well
and then we run it on blockchain
technology that actually increases the
the security of it through immutable
data so when we talk about sharing
economy you mentioned some of the
players that already exist
and we talk about car sharing home
sharing there's there's some other ones
that sort of come immediately to mind
but this is a much bigger sort of I
don't know if I want to call it industry
or space then maybe people understand
right I mean can you talk about some of
the other areas of the sharing economy
sure so since we launched the
development of the platform we've been
approached by all sorts of companies
there's a wedding dress rental company
in in Las Vegas that wants to use our
platform agricultural business so in the
business-to-business sense where you've
got communities of farms and farmers
that need to they want to share their
combined harvest there's an agricultural
equipment transport industry so the the
sharing of the shipping containers
between transport companies that happens
all the time but it's not very well
managed or regulated through a good
marketplace so you talked about some of
the advantages for the end user of
having for example one login that they
can use for both home share and ride
sheriff just just as examples right
what's the advantage from the
infrastructure side of having all of
this happening on one blockchain yeah so
I guess some of the areas I mean if you
look at the advantage from the provider
side so the company that is sharing
their their products out number one is
it's a far greater audience so they get
visibility through our system to a much
lighter of larger audience that they
wouldn't have been able to tap into
previously it is global so they're not
just targeting their small community
that they operate within they do get
better security in terms of that that ID
validation so somebody comes up and
shows their ID all they're doing at the
moment is you're looking at it they're
saying yes that's okay what we do is we
actually do background checks on on the
ID before the person can rent something
and then there's also reputation so like
Airbnb they have you know four or five
star reviews but this isn't just
dedicated to home sharing this is
dedicated to the sharing of anything so
if you rent that wedding dress in Las
Vegas and you rip it and dirty it when
you try to rent a car in Thailand for
example your reputation is going to be
lower so there's a lower chance that you
like
they'd be able to get a good cross so
good insurance on that rental yeah I'm
interested in talking about that
verification part a little bit because
it's become very in vogue to talk about
you know ID verification through the
blockchain background checks through the
blockchain recorded on the blockchain
but that's a big thing right like not
actually doing the background check part
and not being able to fully trust the
people that you're dealing with we know
for some of these other sharing economy
companies has been a real problem
including leading to major major
settlements financial settlement
settlements so like what is it what does
it really mean what are we talking about
when we say that part of your platform
will be ensuring that you can trust the
people you're dealing with
yeah so I mean Trust comes in a few
different forms one is just checking
checking the idea and also validating
that idea against government databases
what this reports and things like that
the trust also happens in in a broader
sense in terms of you know just showing
your ID doesn't mean that you're a
trusted person to be able to rent
something so you know we we use ongoing
reviews and ratings there's an option to
reach out that seems like social
networks to actually look at you know is
this is this person real do they you
know so they have good ratings on other
systems and things like that so one of
the things with blockchain is we have a
immutable data set and what that means
is that once the data goes in there it
can't be changed so like I said with
that wedding dress once you get a one
star review on that no one's going to go
into that database I have it or change
it the other thing that's important to
note is what changes generally public
they're a public ledger that anyone can
query in Access so we don't store the
person's data in the blockchain we store
the facts that this person's data has
this person's ID has been checked and we
store the rating and things like that so
there is no way to actually connect that
blockchain to that individual unless you
are sort of us or one of the providers
as well the sort of next sort of step in
the process after you establish this
system for ID verification trust score
rep
tation system etc is that some of the
right sharing economy players that we
mentioned some of the legacy players
they have had real issues when it comes
to regulation right so we've seen uber
and lyft have major problems in
different parts of the world when it
comes to whether it's a sort of mafia
like taxi Commission not wanting them in
or just you know serve more benign and
practical reasons why they may be kept
out Airbnb that has been a problem when
it comes to you know you're staying in
someone's place someone that you don't
actually know so then right around the
corner is the regulation piece so talk a
little bit about how that regulation
piece could impact what share ring is
doing is it something that you welcome
is it something you're concerned about
sure so he's one thing that's
interesting about what we're developing
in terms of the marketplace so the
providers actually the the providers
that come onto the platform can be any
type of provider it could be a hotel it
could be an Airbnb type provider or
something like that so in terms of
regulation the regulation would
generally happen on the provider side
and then also potentially the data that
we store so you've got G & G GDP are in
in Europe which is the new privacy
legislation there so we need to make
sure that that that our system and
marketplace adheres to that regulation
but in terms of what you can rent on
what you can sell in certain countries
that really comes down to the providers
that come onto our platform so we really
put the onus on them to make sure that
their regulation the regulation is is
done that they're legally in the country
that they're renting their products out
in for example right so if I'm
understanding correctly the advantage to
your platform and its existence on the
blockchain and we'll get to the token in
a moment is that payments across country
lines will be facilitated the engagement
of services across country lines will be
facilitated but still providers would be
subject to the regulation within the
country in which they operate yeah
absolutely so you look at it a good
example or in analogies if you look at
Amazon so Amazon provides a marketplace
for anything you can purchase any
so you can purchase groceries or things
like that so in some countries where
amazon has launched there's certain
products you can't buy on the amazon
platform but in other countries you can
buy that product so Amazon doesn't sell
their own products Amazon allows
different companies to come on to their
in Korea and and add their products to
the Amazon Marketplace Amazon takes care
of the e-commerce or logistics and all
of that so it's probably the closest
analogy to what we're developing with
sharing except it's for the sharing in
the rental economy so we've dealt with
why blockchain that's sort of like part
one of anytime I talk to people who are
doing projects that are on the
blockchain and doing AI cos why do you
need the blockchain at all right because
it's become also a fad in a sense to do
whatever on the blockchain and we've
sort of addressed that why the ico is
sort of the next part in other words
what is the how will the token or in
your case it's actually two different
tokens what purpose do the tokens serve
and what is the sort of impetus for
doing the ico yeah okay so so basically
with the the RTO that we're running
we're actually developing our own
blockchain as part of this so when
you're developing your own blockchain
you need people to individuals that that
are interested in blockchain or actually
want to be part of that blockchain
technology to help run that blockchain
so they install something on their
computers that becomes part of what you
call the consensus model which is
basically the blockchain distributed
among thousands of computers worldwide
so part of that is we need the utility
or the token that we're selling to be
available to as many people as possible
and an ICO is a way to get those tokens
out there so for us because we're
developing your own blockchain that's a
very very important part of distributing
the token the other thing is see in
terms of those people that host those
nodes they need a way to actually earn
money from hosting those they'll get
rewarded for hosting those so they
receive share tokens for hosting those
nodes and and and part of running the
ICO is to basically put a value on those
shared opens to go to those node holders
so there's that and then also the
benefit of running the ICO
is we have the funding to actually build
the platform itself so if you look at it
for as a as their equity investment so
someone invested in our company versus
sovereign investing in our tokens the
total is a better is a better concept
because they're investing in the
blockchain consults so they're actually
contributing to the blockchain to buy
those tokens and getting rewarded for
the actual growth of that blockchain and
being part of a consensus more can you
talk a little bit about the two tokens
there's the shrp token and then the sh r
token and we've we've talked to some
icos that are doing two tokens but most
just have one so I'm interested in that
yeah so the the two tokens are basically
say Charlie to share token so share
token creates the utility of the
platform so when I say the utility what
I mean is that when providers come on
board they when they add an asset or
rent out an asset or do anything on the
blockchain they pay something similar to
a transaction fee and that transaction
fee is paid in share token and then the
consensus holders which of the people
are host part of the blockchain receives
share token as a reward for hosting that
blockchain so that the miners that some
people call them um so that's the share
token and that's what we're selling
Accio the other thing we've created is
something called share pay and share
pays basically our payment system that
sits behind all of the providers and all
of the users so the reason why we've
created this share pays we've created is
something called a stable point and what
that means is it's not a cryptocurrency
that's put on exchanges you can't trade
it or anything like that
it's simply a token that we post on our
block chain that allows people to pay
for the goods and services now the way
that the way that you buy that is you
simply enter your credit card details on
our app or your bank details on an area
in the background we automatically
convert you say your u.s. dollars to
share pay and when the provider in
Thailand who you're renting the car off
receives their payment they receive it
inside out with no foreign currency
transfer fees so what that means is we
give an instant transfer there's no
foreign currency transfer fees because
we're using local banking systems and
we're using the crypto currency to
basically go across the the foreign
truck
how does sharing make money so we make
we also make money from the share token
transaction fees so 50% of the
transaction fees goes to the node
holders and 50% go to us and our
partners so we will have some channel
partners in various locations we
announce the channel partner in Hong
Kong a few weeks ago and those channel
partners will work with us on bringing
other providers onto the platform and
also reviewing those providers I'd love
generally to hear from you this is sort
of a more meta issue in the space right
now but there's more and more discussion
of sort of the environmental impact of
some of the mining activities that are
going on like Bitcoin right so Bitcoin
is sort of the classic one where because
of the difficulty for mining Bitcoin
increasing significantly the amount of
electricity that's going to this this is
sort of an increasing concern that
exists in the space as someone who's
developing on the blockchain but not
specifically in a way that is exactly
alike to to what is going on with
Bitcoin we're we're what's your sort of
perspective on that issue I think it
needs to change I think some some
reports that I read recently is that you
know the amount of power used by mining
is the same as a small nation so you say
Ireland or something like that so it's
it's highly inefficient we when we were
looking at developing our own blockchain
we specifically looked away from energy
intensive mining and looked towards
something what we call it's called proof
of stake so the idea behind proof of
stake is that people to hold the token
stake those tokens in return for being
part of that consensus and it doesn't
require huge amounts of power it's
basically just a standard computer you
can run it on your laptop with a very
low power to do that so you know the
ethos with what we're creating with
sharing is a little bit doing good for
the world it's all about reducing waste
so if we started doing highly intensive
mine then it would kind of go against
the purpose of what we're creating so I
think when you look at other platforms
like a theory of material is moving
towards proof of stake in the future so
you know they are moving away from that
energy intensive mining
can't see Bitcoin doing that anytime
soon there's no proposals up to move it
away from mining so you know I
definitely agree that it does need to
change in the long term is it that
simple is it about moving to proof of
stake and away from from proof of work
or is there sort of more to it that's
gonna need to change longer-term yeah I
think it's a longer term process you
know that there is some test nets up for
a theorem on proof of stake at the
moment that are being tested but you
know part of it is to make sure that you
know the people that are hosting that
consensus or hosting those miners
actually get a good earn rate as well so
they're still earning the same men and
money because it's essentially them that
vote on moving to that different model
from the proof of work which is the
mining to the proof of state model Tim
can you just give us a brief overview of
the stages of the token sale and sort of
the timeline yeah so we're at the end of
our presale at the moment we're raising
about twenty five million dollars for
that so we're still in negotiations with
a few funds and family offices that are
coming on board and then next week tune
the fourth at midnight GMT zero we start
our main sale so we're raising ten
million dollars during the mainsail part
of the process to get into the mainsail
is to be whitelisted and do a what's
called a know your customer check so
that's basically going on the site
secure site putting your ID on there and
then you'll be what's called whitelisted
and then basically to get involved with
it you said aetherium to a contract
address that we set up and you'll
receive tokens immediately in return in
terms of development we've got a proof
of concept development running already
through our sister company keys so we've
partnered with my previous company keys
which is a very large car sharing
company white label car sharing company
so that's running we've also got some
demos running on on the blockchain as
well that we're testing at the moment
we're looking at launching our pilot
partners in November October November of
this year and that will be
limited pilot will be running at about
200 providers and they'll be running
from various features of the system so
some may be just part of our directory
within marketplace others may be using
the token itself others may be using
smart contracts some may be using
external telematics devices to say
unlock doubles or something like that so
what we want to do as part of the file
is to sort of get a wider range of
providers onboard to test the various
features and the things that they need
you can find out more about sharing at
sharing that network we've been speaking
with sharing CEO and co-founder Tim boss
Tim thanks so much for talking to me
about this thanks very much thanks for
your time